well last year these two teams met up in
the postseason as part of the wild card
series now there are a lot of new faces
on both sides we'll see one of those new
faces tonight
in joe musgrove for the padres 28 year
old making his eighth
start we know about the no hitter that
was the highlight of this season for joe
and the franchise
that eighth start his tenth against the
redbirds remember he was a bucko
in pittsburgh in the same division so
he's familiar with this lineup
so two down two on and here is yada yada
molina
lined and caught the third base by manny
machado
you get good starting pitching and you
have a chance johann oviedo
is going to try to keep that trend going
in his third start of the year
the hyundai pitch arsenal here for
johann oviedo force him change up
good slider very good slider has the
curve ball as well
trent grisham leads it off
as a grounder up the middle ranging his
carpenter
long throw and no chance infield hit for
trent grisham
great way to start off the night for the
padres and trent grisham
lead runner on here for the padres in
the bottom of the first inning and
well the padres lineup looks different
these days
of course with the covid situation going
on for the padres and
a change here manny machado sliding up
to the two spot in the order
and this is lying to left o'neal is not
gonna get there it's gonna one-hop the
wall
grisham headed for third and beyond
they're gonna send him
throw to the plate will be cut off and
the padres take a one-nothing lead
nanny machado driving in the night's
first run
oviedo pitches with two on two outs
oviedo's pitch
uh fastball dribbled up the first base
line fielded by oviedo who wins the race
to the bag
by about a foot just barely just barely
beat the speedy grisham
one unassisted for the out now we'll
have to face nolan arenado with the
bases loaded here with one out
25th pitch of the inning is a ground
ball towards second base marcano to
second for one
on to first from double play
nicely turned by the padres defensively
to get out of the bases loaded jam
marcano to kim the cronin work padres
have a one-nothing advantage but a
chance here to
add on where the base is loaded
nobody out jake woodford the new pitcher
for the cardinals after a very tough
outing for johann oviedo
who's responsible for all three on brian
o'grady
the bases filled with friars
fly ball headed to left center field
harrison bader getting himself set
will make the catch tagging at third is
machado he will
score and the padres take a two-nothing
lead
sac fly for brian o'grady
aces loaded again with one out this time
for tucupida marcano
so ground ball softly hit right side
out there and that's all they're gonna
get run scores in the back door
three-nothing padres
out of the baseline was nola the
indication by the second base umpire
greg gibson
arenado came up with runners at first
and second flight to left his
first time up first and second first
pitch to him
and it's hit sharply to short kim no
play
and the base is loaded again for st
louis kim does everything he can just to
slow this thing down
now there are runners at first second
and third for yadier molina
2-2 pitch molina with a fly ball
into ryan near the line o'grady with the
catch
edmond tanking up and he will score
goldschmidt tagging up from second to
third
so the cardinals get on the board that
makes it a 3-1 san diego lead
one out two on two and two to edmond
tough guy to double up he runs really
well
grounded up the middle kim will touch
second and fire to first
double play ha sung kim
6-3 dp 3-1-2 machado now with the runner
in scoring position
[Applause]
in the air to left field o'neal going
back and it is off the wall
grisham's coming around from second
he'll score manny machado is driven in
another run
and the padres take a 4-1 lead
well it's time for the padres to bust
out and take advantage of
the mistakes from the cardinals there's
a mistake from elledge hanging
slider this ball maybe a foot or so from
going out
another line drive anyway you look at it
manny machado drives in a run
brings in nolan aronado with two outs
grounded fair off the sidewall
arenado to second base and he's picked
up another double
and another two head night
[Applause]
but it was another slider just one that
ends up backing up
and nolan doesn't hit it incredibly hard
but finds a home
just right on the line so
second base two down and diana molina
coming up
swinging a mess and he strikes out to
end the ending
two on one away and kivlahan
pinch hitting check swing grabs some bat
or did he grab him but grabbed him now
was he swinging is the question
yeah and kimble hand will be given first
base the hit batsman
and shilton is gonna have to check that
out
because it did appear he was swinging or
they're going to get together that's
what they're going to do
question is is he swinging at this
[Music]
it's not it doesn't even hit him
right yeah it's all bad yeah that's all
bad whoa
oh wow he's just loaded one out
ha sung kim with a chance to open this
thing up a little bit for the padres
fly ball center field bader getting
ready
he'll make the catch tag it third base
so gray the
throw cut off and the padres take a 5-1
lead a sac fly for ken he'd run around
for the cardinals in the eighth tyler
o'neil 143.
o'neal high fly ball out to right
and go on get up it's a home run
and this game has tightened up cardinals
down to their last out
nolan aronado with two outs arenado
a drive into deep left field gone
it's a one-run game now yada year molina
on the ground to first base malanson's
got to get over
proto-worth will tag the bag ball game
over